direction l'ouest et la roche sur yon
pour une expérience unique aux côtés de
benoît je m'apprête à embarquer à bord
d'un avion un peu particulier pour
découvrir un sport extrême la voltige
un bon moyen de prendre de la hauteur et
surtout beaucoup de vitesse et croyez
moi ça vaut le détour
mais tout d'abord je vais rejoindre
françois créateur de top gun voltige
mais surtout passionné d'aviation en
plein travail de restauration de sa
dernière acquisition
rassure moi c'est pas avec ça qu'on va
faire des loopings tout à l'heure non
c'est pas c'est pas avec ça si un avion
tout premiers avions américains à
réaction sorti juste après la deuxième
guerre mondiale et donc on est en train
de le remettre en vol avec une équipe de
passionnés
c'était comme une année qui avait pas
volé cet avion il n'a pas volé depuis à
peu près 15 ans et c'est un avion qui
est sorti celui ci en 56 donc il a 62
ans c'est un vrai passionné d'aviation
est un peu un peu fondu donc tassées
avions tâter boeing et airbus avec
lesquels tu peux pas faire deux loopings
et à la voltige et je la voltige ce avec
toi que je vais voler non c'est pas avec
moi ça avec benoît hamon chef pilote je
te suis pas rouge mais pour le trouver
sa baignoire à la basse et par la suite
indiqué la touche pas
[Musique]
je
salut pennois sa ville natale et
volontaire visite pré vol exactement je
en train de fientes que par l avion pour
ton vol rentes a pris tenta bien checker
mois que plutôt bien dormi bien manger
en pleine forme tout va bien aussi mais
je suis contente
bon maintenant je t'aime de stress et
d'excitation c'est normal avoir un petit
stress avons augmenté la danse est tout
à fait logique
c'est sûr c'est que je plaire il ajouté
une belle tenue est ce qu'il faut que
jamais maître absolu m'engage peut venir
avec mon petit port et un petit sac non
le saxo serait de troubles on va passer
par le vestiaire ils vont se mettre en
tenue puis ensuite feu gérard mas
teigneux de top gun moi aussi je suis
allé bazot
[Musique]
on
nous sommes prêts il est l'heure pour
benoît de me faire son briefing pour me
rappeler les principales consignes de
sécurité en vol de petits conseils je
leur donnerai au fur et à mesure pour
éviter d'être malade le premier c'est de
regarder là où je te dis pendant ce vol
je vais 10 des tonga
car pour que ne soient pas désorienter
si t'as pas désorienter pas malade
d'accord deuxième conseil quand on va
subir les gt le goûter écrasé dans le
siège tu vois que c'est ça ou quand il
faut y ait aucun doute ainsi assez
spectaculaire comme sensations donc
simplement pour être encore à le
supporter tu vas sur un petit peu les
abdos les pectoraux et le fait de rester
gainer tonique je dis pas de trembler je
vais juste faire reste cool tu reste
détendue mais tu sais un petit peu les
abonnés ça va énormément d'être encore
supporter c'est hyper important
[Musique]
la poignée s'en tirer dessus pour
devrait s'il ya besoin c'est celle ci si
jamais c'est ça c'est ça être calme car
la carte hier sur le câble sauvage très
bien d'avoir très clair
[Musique]
le stress commence à monter
concentration maximum en vue d'un
décollage imminent
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
besson
y
[Musique]
cette bagarre de bar
l'amendement
jonathan est un départ en douceur
[Musique]
monsieur
reprendre
[Musique]
j'arrive à la fin de mon voyage et quel
voyage j'espère que vous en avez pris
plein les yeux et plein les oreilles